Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
It's been a while since we put out an episode.
Welcome back.
Today, I have Dr. Andrew Fisher on the show.
Andy and I work at the same hospital here in Albuquerque, New Mexico.
Andy is the namesake of a group on social media called the St. Fisher Church of Evidence-Based
Medicine.
They've got an Instagram page that sort of combines free open access medical education
with humor to help folks in our field better understand the details of what we do in an
informal sort of way.
Anyways, Andy knows lots of stuff about trauma management and out of hospital care, so I
brought him on to talk about a few concepts that sometimes come up in that realm.
Before we get into it all, just know that things we say are personal opinions and do
not reflect the stance or stances of wherever we work.
Thanks for joining me, Dr. Fisher.
Andy.
We got him on the show today to talk about trauma stuff in general.
Some of you may already know him, but real quick, just as a means of introduction, how
about I explain what I think about you or what I think I know and then you can correct
me.
Or just acknowledge it.
Yep, that's me.
So Andy Fisher is a doctor.
That part is right.
True.
He's doing a surgical residency at the University of New Mexico Hospital.
Yes.
And in a prior life, you were a ranger medic.
No.
Common misconception.
To explain.
I was a loving Bravo infantry man back in the 90s in Ranger Regiment.
And when I got out, I worked in EMS.
And when I came back into the military, I went to the interservice physician assistant
program and then was assigned to first range battalion.
This is the A.
Okay, awesome.
Cool.
And then what is on your, this is the part I don't know.
What is on your agenda for when you're done here in Albuquerque?
You're going to stick around and be in New Mexican forever?
I think that that all depends.
Yeah, there's a lot of different options out there.
Right now I'm going to pursue a surgical critical care or acute care surgery fellowship.
Right on.
And then I hope to work in academic medicine and love one trauma center.
Awesome.
Yeah.
And then tell me about your sainthood.
I feel like John or Nick should be here to talk about that.
Well, my main question is, because I haven't been to church in years, my understanding
is that to become a saint, you have to have miracles attributed to you.
Yes.
It's a miracle that I haven't killed John yet.
That's probably how I get in that church.
No, I, you know, honestly, it's kind of sort of as a joke between John and a couple of
people.
And it kind of grew from there.
John has, so John and I have been together now for I think probably about five years.
And Nick joined probably, God, at least three years ago, at least.
And so the three of us, and, you know, obviously we partner with a lot of great people, including
yourself and other organizations, people in general.
And so we just overall just kind of look to expand upon the idea of evidence-based
medicine and kind of free online access to medical education rights to the FOMED aspect.
Again, it really just kind of started off as a joke.
And somehow we just ended up down this pathway to where we're like, how does this happen?
Why do we have so many people that actually pay attention to us?
It's probably inappropriate.
And if they actually, I think if they knew us altogether, they'd be like, nah, I'm going
to have to cut a sling.
Yeah, you guys do have a significant following.
So that's awesome.
Cool.
Well, I guess I, for a while, over the last year or so since we've met, have just been
kind of collating a list of questions about trauma management in general, anything relevant
for people who work in EMS.
And I think your experience, like with your medical background and your military experience,
and now with your surgical residency, you are like pretty well suited to answer some
of these questions.
I hope so.
Sounds awesome.
Yeah, I guess I always preface it with like, you know, while I think I may have a great
idea or kind of maybe a decent idea about what to do, I don't know, like that oftentimes
I kind of show up and I'm like, we're looking for good enough.
Yeah, I just have to show up.
I just have to show up.
And some of these things, like not everything has a straight answer.
Right.
I guess that's the challenging part about it is like, what is the right answer?
And often we don't know is that we kind of have to make our best guess at the time and
go ahead.
I think that's, you know, a failed part of I think evidence-based medicine that isn't
necessarily appreciated as kind of like a clinical aspect that you kind of have to buy
in and kind of have to use your consult a little bit in order to kind of make some decisions.
And I've learned that throughout my career, certainly.
And I think we kind of learned that early on.
For sure.
Yeah.
Quote, unquote, church.
Cool.
Well, I guess we'll just dive into this list of questions and see where it takes us.
The first question I have for you is, is there ever a reason to unpack a wound in the field?
And the reason I asked that question is that a lot of folks on the EMS side are taught
never to take it dressing down once it's packed.
And I'm just curious to know your thoughts on that.
I think whenever you look at what we do in the OR, you know, say someone has a gunshot
wound to the abdomen and, you know, we take them up there and we, you know, open them
up.
First thing we do is try to evacuate all the clots, right?
Kind of get all the clots out and then we pack the abdomen with a bunch of laparotomy
pads.
But then we take them out and we're going to try to identify any sort of bleeding.
So I think it's appropriate.
I think if you look at the, in fact, if you look at the guidelines, at least in the T-C-C
guidelines, it says that you can pack or un, you know, leave packed and then repack around
it or just, you know, pack new.
I'm more in favor of repacking.
So I would pull stuff out.
I pulled the clots out and tried to identify where the bleeding is because clearly if it's
still bleeding through either I'm not effective or I need to do some other intervention.
So I don't really know until I actually get a look at it.
Right.
That's fair.
I think a lot of times on the EMS side when we see blood coming through a dressing, we
just layer it up.
But what we need is directed pressure.
We can't do that if there's a bunch of stuff.
Yeah.
I think direct pressure works overall.
I think you can do it on top of dressings, but I think if you continuously kind of layer
it on, later on, later on, it becomes, it does become less effective because now you're
kind of trying to distribute this pointed focus of pressure onto a more, a broader surface,
which it becomes effective.
So either can apply direct pressure on the wound or you can pack effectively and hopefully
not have to repack.
But some wounds do actually, will bleed through and what are you going to do?
Put a tourniquet.
Right.
And that leads me to my next question along these same lines.
What about taking a tourniquet down in the field?
Yeah, I'm confused why EMS doesn't do that now.
I think if you look at overall, there's a lot of tourniquets that are just, they're
applied rapidly in a certain situation because of the level of training based on the responder,
whether it be law enforcement bystander, maybe even EMS or fire.
But there are a lot of wounds that are clearly, it's not indicated.
And I think it would be beneficial for EMS to learn how to pick those down and just evaluate
them, even if it's just like, Hey, I'm going to go ahead and pack this wound and then I'm
going to take the drink it down and see how it looks.
Right.
And this is something that has been a topic of conversation for a long time on the wilderness
medicine side of things, but I haven't seen it cross over much to the civilian side.
I think we'll hopefully see some changes soon.
You know, some people from here, from the University of Mexico, we recently submitted
a paper that kind of discusses the idea of converting tourniquets in the pre-hospital
setting because, you know, especially here in places like this where evacs maybe, you
know, four or five hours.
So why shouldn't we, from my perspective, you know, why shouldn't we be teaching, you
know, EMS professionals to take down a wound or take down a tourniquet and evaluate the
wound if it needs a tourniquet grade, if it needs a pressure dressing grade, or it just,
you know, kind of a reactionary sort of situation, then that's fine too.
But we're getting it down early.
And what about a time limit on that?
If we can get someone to a trauma center, say a level one in an hour, two hours, don't
worry about it.
Or is it something where like time is always relevant and you should take a tourniquet
down if you can.
No, my personal belief is that it's always relevant.
And you know, clearly the data suggests that up to two hours is perfectly safe.
But at the same time, you know, I'd like to fully use the full abilities of our EMS
professionals.
And if that is, you know, recognizing the fact that a tourniquet is going to be up,
then we should take it down.
One it's, it's not a benign intervention, even though it's, you know, quote unquote,
safe for two hours, it's not benign.
And additionally, it's painful.
And so, you know, do if I don't need it on, what's the reason?
And then if you look at the overall level response that you get from a tourniquet application,
no matter where you are, it's going to be a significant trauma level response that may
not necessarily be beneficial to the patient in terms of logistics and cost and overall
required intervention.
Yeah, that definitely makes sense.
So for folks in the field, if you get to the point where you've had a chance to get your
head up and think about reevaluating your interventions, like if you have time for a
secondary assessment, think about taking it down.
Yeah, exactly.
It's very similar to like tactical field care, right?
So you know, I'm going to kind of step or take a step back.
I'm going to kind of look at what we've done, say look at the injuries, kind of go from
head to toe again.
You know, someone shows up in the ED, they, you know, we go through a whole set of different
stuff before the tourniquet ever is a question of coming down.
So yeah, take the opportunity to investigate everything, determine if the patient is stable,
and if so, I think it should be a reasonable option to expect paramedics to intervene.
Cool.
Next question about bleeding.
What are your thoughts on carrying hemostats to clamp arterial bleeding?
That's a terrible idea.
I don't, I came in and entertained that question.
It's absolutely awesome.
How do you look cool if you don't carry hemostats in your flight suit?
Yeah, I mean, but if you look at the, even look at the ATLS guidelines, right?
So ATLS says do not clank.
You will, there's the potential for injuring other underlying structures and overall completely
missing the vessel is significant.
So and I think a lot of the time the perception is that like having hemostats to clamp on
artery will be straightforward and that when you clamp it, there won't be collateral damage.
My understanding is that it's quite hard to identify like where you need to clamp and
then those jagged edges on the hemostats can cause injury as well.
Yeah.
Hey, you know, we take people to the operating room and we often have to make large incisions
in order to access approximately the control of the vessel.
And then we look at, you know, at that point, controlling the hemorrhage and decide how
we're going to repair it if we need to repair it.
So the idea that like, I'm just going to go ahead and just going to stick the hemostat
in here and clamp it is foolish and a bit naive.
You know, I'm going to be so bold to say that I didn't carry hemostats at one point when
I was, you know, in the pre-hospital setting that I didn't think it was a viable option.
So you know, that's my point.
Like I've been there, I thought it was a good idea.
And I say, that's a good idea, but it's something that I could do, you know, and I think I've
got to the point now, based upon the evidence is like, nah, I can either pack, I can hold
pressure or I can put on a lip tourniquet.
Right.
Yeah.
There are also plenty of other reasons why folks carry hemostats.
Like when I wrap patients up in burritos, I use it to clamp the sheet on top of them
to keep their arms in.
Or if I don't have a pressure infuser, I can pump up an autocuff and then use the hemostats
to keep it inflated.
Yeah.
I mean, is this done wrong with hemostats in general?
Just not for that specific thing.
I mean, I used to use it to pack wounds, right?
Because bullet holes are actually pretty small.
Like people want to underestimate the size of them.
And so someone has a tiny hole and it doesn't quite meet criteria for a tourniquet, you know,
you know, I can go ahead and I can pack some breasts, you know, hemostat.
That's awesome there.
I guess that's a use I hadn't thought about, like using it to get that point pressure when
you're packing a wound.
What about hemostatic dressings?
And in particular, if you think the regular like four by four hemostatics have any value
or if it needs to be Z fold to pack?
I think four by four dressings have the same role as a bandaid or, you know, it's just
something to cover something up.
They don't really have a role in actual hemorrhage control of significance.
But if we break down between hemostatics and non-hemostatic dressings for so, you know,
quote, unquote, kirllex or roll gauze versus a hemostatic dressing, whether it's cell
locks or kamikaze or heme con.
Right now, the evidence that we have doesn't necessarily suggest that there is a survival
benefit.
It's not a state that doesn't help control hemorrhage earlier or that we may not have
a benefit later on down the road as we sort of get that gathered a large group of numbers
potentially that we'll start looking at doing more prospective studies.
But at the time, based on the DOD data itself, we don't necessarily have a great benefit.
I think what is most important is the packing technique.
So how do you actually pack?
So are you able to actually identify that bleeding vessel in a large enough wound where
you can kind of put your finger on it?
I feel it here.
I'm going to pack up against it.
I'm going to pack, pack, pack, pack, pack.
I teach just the same thing at Stop the Bleak courses.
So we talk about packing, packing, packing effectively.
And I think that's just the most important.
There's nothing wrong with hemostatic dressings.
If you carry them, that's fantastic.
If you don't, I understand.
And I think you should practice at least in whatever practice packing, practice packing
is because it can be a lot more challenging than I think people expect.
Right.
And let's say you don't have hemostatics or you don't want to shell out 30 to 40 bucks
to buy the Z-fold hemostatics.
What about using just roller gauze or curlix?
Right.
And that's what I'm saying is the packing technique is most important.
Yeah.
So get in there, identify that source of bleeding, pack, pack, pack, get a good pressure
rest on top of that.
Try not to create such a significant venous tronic kit whenever you do kind of the pressure
resting, but you should be able to at least control the hemorrhage from with effective
packing techniques.
Right on.
I want to change gears a little bit.
What are your thoughts on keeping a jiggly saw in a kit or something comparable in the
event that you had to do a field amputation?
Why can't you just use a regular saw like maybe the fire department has or?
I guess the question comes from that I used to work for a program that carried a saw in
our kits because we were in an area that didn't have extrication.
Although I guess cutters or saw the fire department has in most places works just fine.
I'm not saying that's the best method to go about.
Hey, I'm going to break out these big ass saw here.
Pay no attention while I saw your leg off.
I think it's a great option.
All right.
What are we talking about?
We were talking about field amputations.
I think that field amputations are necessary intervention that may be required from counter
time.
How you go about it is totally dependent on what you have available.
You know, if you have a jiggly saw fantastic.
If you have a saw saw, I mean, whatever you got to use.
You got to do the job.
I think the most important part is, you know, making sure your patient's stable and probably
sedated for the procedure.
I've done, you know, amputations and pre-alpha setting were so mangled that it's just like
it's almost like sniffing skin.
Can you really even count that as amputation?
You can't, but you know, it's just like snipping off some soft tissues.
But yeah, if you need to go through bone due to mangled extremity, I think you should have
something that has been demonstrated to work.
I know there's been, you know, some pre-hospital studies done on different, I guess, improvised
techniques.
And they all seem to work effectively.
It's just, I think people are pretty smart in the pre-hospital setting.
And you know, people are going to show up that have this, some sort of, I think, base
knowledge, whether it be a medical director or more experienced paramedic, they can say,
hey, you know, this is what we have available because this is what, you know, we've been
demonstrated to kind of work in our situations.
Right on.
Cool.
Next question I have is about airway management and trauma.
What are your thoughts on an awake crike versus an RSI or like a delayed sequence intubation?
I think they were, those are different things.
I think we're talking about a situation where.
Yeah, I guess I can give some context where you have a severely injured person who is
at risk for like cardiac arrest or hemodynamic collapse with agents we normally use intubation.
If you think there's ever a reason to go straight for a crike for somebody versus pushing drugs
and having a bad outcome.
And the answer can totally be no.
I think, I just think the idea that somehow you're going to do an awake crike and it's
just going to be this calm sort of like, oh, instead of doing RSI, I'm just going to do
an awake crike.
I think it's a little bit of a fantasy world.
But I also think that RSI and hemorrhagic shocks based upon the, you know, the war RDC
are saying that probably Phil Spinella or Gares Janison came up with this, you know,
really stupid ID or really stupid intervention.
You know, it's like there are certain people that absolutely need some sort of airway in
the pre-hospital setting hemorrhagic shock.
But I also believe that you should hold off to the, you know, to the very last moment,
not many last moment, but, you know, to reasonable to say, okay, it's time to innovate this person.
I think probably doing one thing you didn't mention was, you know, the supergloc airway.
So you know, is that also an option, right?
So does someone get to the point to where is it easier to do supergloc airway?
And I think, you know, your target audience is, you know, a lot higher skilled and better
educated than, you know, say like the, you know, the combat medic that's, you know, sitting
the point of injury.
And that's just the fact that, you know, you guys are critical care paramedics, you guys
are nurses and, you know, even PAs or whatever that, you know, take these in-house skills
to the pre-hospital setting, which is a little bit different.
And like there's nothing wrong with being a combat medic, but you guys definitely have
a higher level of skill.
So SGA, yeah, could be, but RSI, DSI is probably overall, I don't even know if there's any
data even to support it, but I would think it would probably be just overall just maybe
a little bit better.
Yeah.
And I know that's something that in the hem scene, there's a lot of, I don't know if you
call it pressure, but like everyone wants to intubate, but in most cases, you'd probably
be fine with BLS airways.
We're super glad to keep it got to that point, as long as the face is intact.
I mean, what, what, which always fascinates me because I remember being a paramedic and
it was like, it seems like maybe the most, the biggest procedure you do, right?
You're going to take someone's airway.
And so I think that has to, has a little bit to do with it, but I'm so fascinated by the
idea that, you know, the pre-hospital setting, we get, we get so focused on airway.
And the fact that it's a time tag, do I, you know, am I going to do this?
And I guess I don't, looking back now, I think it's because it seems like it's such a big
commitment and you're like, this is a big procedure and I'm going to own this.
But I think if we overall look at it, it's, you don't necessarily need to do it in a lot
of settings.
Right.
Yeah.
I think that's like a valuable lesson.
And also this makes me think of that guy we brought to you in the ER a couple of weeks
ago.
He was a guy who was stuck on an 18 wheeler for like two hours and we could only see like
half his face and a shoulder.
So we had all the things set up to manage airway.
And like, as soon as he came out, we did it real quick and then left.
And in hindsight, he probably would have been just fine.
He was altered.
He maybe couldn't protect his airway.
But, you know, we probably would have been okay with the BLS airway.
You know that famous picture that's been floating around the internet for, you know, 20
years about the guy that's kind of leaning forward in the ED?
Oh yeah.
With his face blown off.
Right.
So I was actually, you know, I was like, I can't identify the patient because it's been 20
years, but that was actually at Methodist at Indianapolis.
And it was in, you know, there's two trauma bays there.
But I mean, that's an excellent example that's consistently shown throughout the past 20
years.
It's like here's a guy who clearly has some significant trauma, but he's maintaining his
airway.
And it's always talked about this is a guy who's maintaining his airway because he worked the
proper positioning and he was stable.
He did not require intervention.
And I think, you know, as I said, I still look back now and I'm like, there are a lot of
things that I probably felt like I should have done.
But was it, you know, we back in the day, I mean, you're not quite as old as me, but, you
know, we didn't have RSI back in the day.
And so you either have to like nasally innovate or, you know, do the Kentucky innovation if
you're going to do it on someone.
I'm not familiar with the Kentucky innovation.
I'd say right handed innovation from the face.
What do you guys call it here?
You don't know when you do that right hand innovation.
You throw down when you're facing the patient.
Oh yeah.
Like the Tomahawk you mean?
See, you guys call it the Tomahawk scene.
Yeah.
See, I guess we're from Indiana.
You call it the Kentucky innovation.
I bet people from Kentucky call it the.
Yeah, I think there's a technical name for it.
Like in the walls book, it's like a Mueller technique or something like that.
Okay.
Kentucky innovation.
I think we should just bring back nasal intubation.
Yeah.
Um, yeah, sure.
Do that because I was never, ever, ever successful at doing ever a single nasal
animation.
Yeah, me neither.
I just like, like, um, and if I can think back some of the paramedics I used to work
with, uh, work with at the wish or at the whiz and, uh, dad and, uh, book me 10.
I used to always get a small, small, small town, uh, EMS service called
blooming in the hospital, a remote service by IU.
But he was a guy named named Brian Gay.
There he used to just like, cause I have the trigger, right?
And the trigger on the tube, you do like pull that.
If you had the ones with the trigger, that was ideal, but we used to just take
them and well, I was never successful at this, but you could curl it around your
finger to have like a hyperangulated tip and you slide it in and the thought was
that it'd stay interior, but I never had any luck either.
I, you know, I could, I could probably name off a list of paramedics that, uh,
were just really great at it.
Uh, I could, I was never successful.
I'm Shane Hardwick.
If you're listening to you probably got more than me.
He was a old roommate of mine who was, uh, probably more
talented with the airway than me.
That's all right.
You can't be great at everything.
Uh, yeah.
Funny.
You can't be, you can also not be good at much, but, uh, showing up.
All right.
My next question is about how we do traumatic arrest in a pre-hospital
setting, because for me, it's like fairly different from how things are run in a
hospital setting.
I don't think, I don't think it's much different at all outside of, outside
of doing an emergency, through our economy.
What's the difference?
What are you going to, are you going to confirm that is, uh, compressible
hemorrhage, you have an airway.
I mean, I guess that's the way we could do it.
There are like two approaches in the, so I think, yeah, I think the,
the issue lies is like, you know, do we want a lot of paramedics to do the
exact same thing and I'm not suggesting at all that we should ever, ever do
emergency through our economies.
What I am suggesting that, uh, uh, you know, a lot of places got away from
things like doing CPR.
Um, so now, you know, if I have, I show up, I can open up an airway.
All right.
So I can open up a fair way.
I can do that manually.
I can, I mean, I can have Joe, whatever bystander do that or a law
enforcement firefighter, uh, my partner, whoever, whoever it is open up their way.
The breathing is spontaneous.
Yes or no.
Uh, I can, you know, I can do bilateral simple tort cost to me.
Uh, and I can put an ultrasound on the heart.
You know, if you accomplish those things and nothing is, you know, working
wire, what are we doing?
I mean, overall the outcomes are terrible for traumatic arrests and that sucks,
but that's just the way it is.
I guess I see that most, uh, like pre-hospital providers are still managing
a pre-hospital traumatic arrest.
Like they would the medical ones.
Like the focus is still on compressions.
Do you really see that a lot?
Yeah.
I think, um, yeah, in a pre-hospital setting, I think I've seen a lot of
change over the past three years.
And, uh, for the good.
And I think we're seeing a lot of, uh, holding CPR.
Um, I would like to see more simple tort cost to me.
I don't think needle tort cost to me is necessarily the, well, I know it's not,
it's not the most effective, but I don't think it's essentially effective at all.
Uh, you know, across the country, we've seen, or you can even say around the
world, we've seen that, you know, needle tort cost to me isn't necessarily the
greatest intervention.
And if someone's dead, they're not really getting more dead.
And I, I know it's a cliche and sometimes often kind of, you know, you look at the
things I see in social media, I'm like, that's just a terrible way to go about it.
Um, but in traumatic arrest, um, you know, what do we do?
You know, you, you, you, you should make, I think, uh, bold, uh, decisions, uh, bold
interventions and either do something and transport and they get to a surgeon or
they don't, uh, and again, I think it goes back to opening up an airway, um,
venting the chest and then putting all the time on the heart.
If those three things provide nothing, then your patient, uh, like, I think likely
survival, survival is slim and none.
And that's it.
I mean, that's just, that's not an opinion.
I mean, that's just what the data suggests.
At the moment, there's not at least here in New Mexico.
I don't know to anyone on the ground who's carrying ultrasound.
I know there's some flight crews, but the majority of folks on the ground don't
have ultrasound in the field, but we're constantly bullying everyone that works
above us in these agencies to change that.
Yeah.
And it's not like it's a cheap intervention, right?
It's not like, Oh, I'm going to, I'm going to stick, I'm going to give someone a
14 gauge angio-catholic, but like she sticks us in the chest.
I mean, this is a significant investment.
And a lot of training.
Yeah.
I, I get, maybe I disagree a little bit.
A lot of training.
I don't know if it's a lot of training.
I think it is a little bit training with some, uh, overall just kind of follow up.
Just be like, Hey, come in a couple of times a year.
Just make sure you can still find the heart and you can still
identify whether it's beating or not.
Right.
But the cost of the, uh, the intervention, uh, certainly be pricey.
You mean like buying the machines?
Yeah.
But it's coming down every year.
It's getting cheaper and cheaper.
I own one.
I haven't bought one yet, but I've been tempted.
My butterfly out.
We can watch the sound each other.
Can we record a video?
Um, what about a TXA?
Cause everyone carries TXA because it's super cheap and readily available.
Uh, I guess in general, we'll start with general thoughts on TXA in
the pre-hospital setting.
Yeah.
Sweet.
It's getting great.
The TXA is there.
And do you think it matters so much that we give it right away?
Like as close to the point of injury as possible, or is it okay to give it on the
way?
I think, I think it was most important that a lot of people to kind of
overall federal recognizes not necessarily when, when the mess gets it,
they get to the scene or when they meet the patient or when they end up
give the OR or to the ER, but when was the patient injured?
Right.
So when was the patient injured and what did, how does that play into, you
know, overall, you know, how we treat and treat our trauma patients.
And, uh, you know, TXA is one of those drugs that, you know, over time, obviously
we know after three hours is, you know, we lose that mortality benefit, uh,
for in hospital, uh, you know, I know there's some more recent data that may
suggest that TXA may be more, may be beneficial than I'm willing to
overall, you know, give us a complete thumbs up.
Um, but I think it's important for, for EMS to get on scene when was the patient
injured, we also know this from, from the military is like, when we're, if we're
going to do a blood transfusion, uh, you know, if you look at, uh, um, Colonel
Shackelford and, and what she did, uh, they said, Hey, 34 minutes from injury,
34 minutes from injury.
If I get blood on board, I know I'm going to, you know, potentially have some sort
of significant impact that's going to, um, sway, um, you know, those patients.
And you need to give it within 34 minutes of injury.
Yeah.
And I think we don't, we don't really appreciate that in EMS because
often we're just like, Oh, well, someone comes on the lawn, we're going to show up.
I don't take it to the hospital.
But how do we know that person wouldn't lay out there for an hour or so?
Right.
And so I think, I think we should evaluate, you know, when are we going to give
TXA, um, and when was the patient injured?
Overall, uh, I'm, I've been, I've been pretty vocal about this for many years.
Uh, I'm not a super huge fan of TXA without using blood products.
Uh, I think, uh, we need a, especially in someone who's continues to bleed.
And so, so, so when you continues to bleed, we're, we're already coagulopathic
and we're not giving blood products.
You know, is that TXA is going to bleed the body because what's it, what's it really
doing?
And I'm sure I could, you know, catch a lot of flack from, you know, people
who are much smarter than I am on this topic and this, this opinion.
But I mean, show, show me the data that suggests that pre-hospital TXA, uh,
outside of a couple of studies is super useful.
Yeah.
I think the big holdup here is that TXA is super cheap and blood is super expensive.
But what else does it cost?
Right?
Yeah.
I mean, do you get venous thromboembolisms?
Do you get PEs?
Do you get, uh, you know, other vascular issues?
Those are your problems in the hospital.
Right.
Yeah.
Hey, just, just, just give it and, and just go with it.
And I think that's, I'm not, I'm not going to do bag on EMS for, for, for something
like that, that is going to, you know, where they did thinking about what are we
going to do in the hospital?
Right.
But I, I guess I put it back on the medicine.
Like, I mean, it's still me, uh, you know, we continue to read rate very smart
people out there, they're much better than I am that work on EMS, uh, that, that, you
know, could help kind of put that thought out there.
Right.
What are we doing?
What's going to happen when they get to the hospital?
And maybe, maybe it's because EMS doesn't know because they're not really taught
that in their, in their education pipeline.
Right.
Yeah.
We don't have exposure to what goes on in the hospital.
It's pretty limited.
Like all medics, which I'm sure you remember go do shifts in school, but it's
not to understand how the system works.
It's to get skills.
So it's a different story.
Yeah.
And yeah, you work in the ED and you can do some skills.
Uh, you kind of see maybe they, the trauma team comes down and they take me to OR
and that's like, all right, you know, all right, I'm out.
Uh, even as you go to the OR, what do you do?
You go on there to innovate.
And a lot of times people, you know, after that they may scrub out or they, or maybe
they don't feel comfortable asking, but I, but I think offering, uh, EMS, uh, kind
of insight into what happens in trauma surgery, uh, after they get to the
hospital and after they leave the ER, what's that, what happens and what decisions
are made.
Yeah.
I think that's a good point you bring up.
That is something that doesn't happen a lot.
Um, I don't know how it is in other places, but in New Mexico for hospitals to maintain
their status as a trauma center, they have to do those types of case reviews or
presentations from like start to finish.
Uh, so it does happen.
But I would imagine like the percentage of pre-hospital providers that participate in
those things, myself included, like I've never gone.
Like I know it exists, but in my mind I framed it like it's another meeting that
I don't want to go to.
But you see them when they show up in the ICU, right?
And then you're like, whoa.
Yeah.
My situation is a little different.
I also work in the trauma surgical ICU.
So yeah, it has worked out a couple of times where I've had a patient on scene
and then I've had them or at least seen them on the unit.
That's, that's kind of cool.
Yeah.
That's nice.
And that's nice continuity care.
Yeah.
I think that's pretty unique, but in general, most folks don't have that opportunity.
I guess if I were to pick one area of EMS that would improve, it would be something
like that.
And, uh, you know, hopefully I don't get myself in trouble with, you know, I've
taken a couple of paramedic students up to the OR be like, yeah, you know, put on
some scrubs, come in and watch what we do.
And, uh, yeah, it's, it's, uh, I think it's a great opportunity for them.
You know, they're not, they're not, you know, doing much, you know, the bed debate,
you know, they're, they're wearing the scrubs and they're scrubbed in.
They can at least look over and kind of see what we're doing and kind of
see how we kind of approach things.
Yeah.
No, that's awesome.
I definitely think that would be good for more providers to have that sort of
follow-up and exposure to what goes on in the hospital.
That gives them a whole EMS education, which is on our list.
We'll say that for another time.
Yeah.
Right.
Um, I guess the other questions I have are just general questions.
I'm curious to know a little bit about you.
You've worked in a number of settings.
You were in the military and worked as a civilian medic and then back in
when you got your PA, now you're working on becoming a surgeon.
Uh, how has that transition worked out for you?
Like, what are your thoughts on that trajectory and the different
roles you've had a chance to work in?
I think, I think each step is significantly challenging because, um,
every, every role is different.
Um, I could not say enough amazing things about what we have for the
APPs we have in, you know, at our hospital.
You don't have to say that just because I'm in an AP school.
Okay.
All right.
They're all terrible, but no, they're, they're really fantastic.
And, and, uh, they do an amazing job and, and I always try to at least
recognize the role they play.
Uh, but you know, my first year of PA school, um, you know, I went through
the iPad program, uh, I didn't find it super challenging that that portion.
Um, you know, probably a little more challenges.
I think maybe once we got to the clinical setting, because it's different, you know,
you look at it from pre-hospital setting and no, I am here to take care of
emergencies as well, you know, when you're a PA, you're, you're, you're not.
You may take care of emergencies, but your goal is not to simply learn
emergency medicine, your, your goal is to learn how to be the PA and how to
learn in all aspects of medicine.
And so from there it was, you know, you had to make that jump.
And, uh, you know, I think took me a bit to be able to recognize that.
Um, uh, the jump from PA to medical school was, uh, seeing the
empirically emotional event, uh, super challenging.
Uh, medical school is a challenging self-surgery residency is, um, it's
just, I don't know how to describe it other than it's hard.
And you know, I work a lot, a lot of hours and a lot of hours that, you
know, I don't log, right, because I come home and you can, you're, we're
in my house right now and we can see, I have one, two, three, four, five,
five, six books, six books that, that, um, that have out, um, I mainly use
two of them, um, but, uh, you know, I have a whole book on, you know,
dictation and, uh, it's that blue book right there.
And, you know, I look in there, you know, I look up cases beforehand.
I read about the patient, I read about the procedure.
I'll go back and I'll look at the, the, uh, attending previous operations
and see how he did that operation.
And so I have an understanding about how this surgeon male and female
may approach it, may approach it.
Uh, and that's just their specific thing.
I also have to know about, you know, what's the pathophysiology, what's the
anatomy, what's, uh, what's the overall risk of things like leaks or, you know,
adverse outcomes or, uh, other significant events that really kind of
impact morbidity and mortality.
Uh, being a, being trained to be a surgeon is something completely different.
It's not impossible.
Um, many people do it.
I'm a knuckle dragger, you know, and I'm, I'm quote unquote making it.
But, you know, I, I'm not, I'm not dumb, but I'm not the sharpest off in the drawer.
Uh, I think each step you should recognize what you're going, what you, what
you're, what is your goal and if you want to be a nurse practitioner or PA, fantastic.
Uh, but also think if you have ever thought about being, becoming a physician,
D O or MD, um, you should think about that.
Um, take some time to think about it before you kind of decide what you're
doing, PA MP or, uh, or D O MD and, uh, and make your decision based upon what
you think you want to do a lot.
Again, our amazing APPs do fantastic job every single day.
Uh, I chose to jump from PA to, uh, become a physician because I wanted to operate.
And even though there's a lot of great APPs that work in surgery, um, I wanted
to be the one that was doing the operation.
I want to be the person that was making a decision.
Uh, I'm working a little bit haphazardly here and I'm digressing a little bit.
Um, I went to EMT school when I, or an EMT course when I was enlisted, that when
I was an infantry guy, and that was the thing that said, Oh man, I really like
medicine.
It was a really, I mean, I was successful as, um, I am free ranger, uh, but, um,
I really kind of kind of, it's kind of stuck to me and it was like one of the
first things I was like, man, I really enjoy it.
And I'm not, I'm not terrible if that makes sense.
Uh, you know, I didn't necessarily have a, um, a regular pathway.
Obviously you don't end up being a middle-aged man, being a fourth year
surgery resident, but you know, it was like, it was something I enjoyed doing.
And, um, I kind of pursued things as I, as I found them, uh, if I had to go back,
I'd probably go, you know, I had to go go into medical school when I got out of the
army and, you know, life takes you in different directions.
I wouldn't give up my PA time and the army and, and December hits the range
regiment for anything, uh, but I've had to do it again.
And, uh, you know, hindsight.
Yeah, I probably go straight to medical school and, uh, go that route, but I
probably actually would end up in emergency medicine, which I probably
eventually would have disliked a little bit.
Nothing wrong with it.
Um, it's just.
Uh, after moonlighting doing as a PA, I'm like, I don't want to do this as a
position.
And so I was like, I really want to be a surgeon.
And, uh, man, it's, it's, it's an amazing, uh, pathway I've been on.
Uh, but I would recommend that everyone kind of take the opportunity, especially
if you're an EMS, you know, become a physician, do it.
There's nothing to stop you from doing it.
And you know, I've talked to Jason picket about this, um, or Jr.
Pickett.
I've talked to a lot of people about this and I've, I've tried to kind
of put that a little bit of wisdom out there.
And I understand like, uh, we've all been, you know, in our early 20s, late
twenties, early thirties, whoever were like, ah, I think I know best.
Uh, I would just take the opportunity to the pause for a second, figure out what
you really want to do, and then you should go for it because I, I have little
doubt that every single paramedic out there, uh, every single paramedic
out there, uh, you know, if you're an EMT, you become a physician, you become a
P.A. You become a paramedic, uh, recognize that, uh, know what your goals are and go
for it.
Awesome.
Well, that's all the questions I had.
I don't know if there's anything else you had or if we'll just stop there.
Yeah.
I'm, I'm so happy that we were finally able to start talking to you.
I'm so happy that you're able to, um, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to,
to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to,
to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to, to,
to let that goal go.
Thank you very much.
My pleasure.
Thanks to Dr.
A most sweet Comey in.
Last quarter, in season three, I had not heard about her question on me,
but primarily she makes things various about her powers.
We were able to showcase it to brothers and sisters regardingiff,
St. Fisher folks have been instrumental in getting our stuff out there into the world
and we truly appreciate that.
And then we'll end things with a shout out to my good friend Josh Pittman and his buddy
Kevin Pons.
They put the music together for the show.
Until next time.